وبعد مرور اسبوع على الزلزال واقتراب
عمليات الانقاذ والانتشال من نهايتها بدا
الان الكلام يكثر عن الخسائر الماديه
السوريه الى الان ما في اي شيء واضح او
رسمي لا عدد المباني المدمره ولتقديرات
الحجم الخسائر الماديه ولا شيء اما تركيا
فبداوا في احصاء الخسائر امس مع اعتقال او
سمعنا اخبار عن اعتقال عدد من المتعهدين
المسؤولين عن بناء عمارات ومجمعات من
الانهارت بالكامل وفي تحقيقات وملاحقات
لمتعهدين اخرين بتهمه الاهمال والبناء
بطرق مخالفه ومن ساعات اعلن القبض على
مالك شركه مسؤوله عن بناء عدد من المباني
في اضنه هيئه الكوارث التركيه بتقول او
بتقدر انه عدد المباني اللي دمرت بالكامل
6444 مبنى والاتحاد الشركات والاعمال في
تركيا بتوقع ارتفاع عجز الموازنه من 3.5
الى 5.4 بسبب في الميه طبعا بسبب جهود
اعاده الاعمار بتقول انه خسائر تركيا تقدر
مليار دولار وهذا يشكل 10% من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي للبلد اما تكلفه اعاده
الاعمار فيقدر بانها راح تستهلك
5.5% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي ورغم
تاكيدات اردوغان من كم يوم انه حيرجعوا
يعمروا البلد خلال سنه لكن خبراء بيقولوا
انه هذا صعب كثير وانه الموضوع راح ياخذ
سنوات على الاغلب